Today, I will show you a quick recap of
the last eight trades that I took using
my super sample strategy taking only one
trade per day 90% of the time. Why I
took this trades, how I placed my stop
loss, and also the exact entry trigger
that I use on this account. And if you
want a full breakdown of my strategy
that get me numbers like this on only
one account, I will leave the full
detailed breakdown in the description.
So, let's start with Monday, the 22nd of
June. On this day, market opened here. I
was bullish because the price is over
all the EMAs, especially the 1-hour one.
I kept waiting for a VG to be printed in
this downtrend, but it didn't happen. We
break through the 1-hour EMA, that means
my bias was switched. I was bearish for
the day. Then, I waited for a bullish
FVG to be formed, as you can see here.
Price broke through it with this candle.
I entered, placed my stop loss over the
FVG, over the inversion candle, and over
the previous candle. Then, I was stopped
out here and call it a day. I lost 3K
because this is my risk for this
account. Now, let's jump to the next
day. As you can see here, price opened
here. It's below all the three EMAs.
They are pointing down, so my bias was
bearish for that day. Then, I waited for
a bullish FVG to be printed, as you can
see here. Then, we broke it with this
candle. I entered, placed my stop loss
over the FVG, over the inversion candle,
and also the previous candle. So, I had
three layers of protection and targeted
this week as a liquidity. My RR was
3.21. I made almost 10K for that day.
This is a textbook setup. Now, let's
jump for our next day. This is the same
exact thing that happened on the
previous day. Price opened below the
three EMAs, especially the 1-hour one.
Then, I waited for an FVG, a bullish FVG
to be printed. We have one here. Price
broke it with this candle. I placed my
stop loss over the FVG, over the green
EMA, and also over the inversion candle,
and targeted this previous week as a
liquidity. The RR was also three, so I
made a little bit over 9k. Now, let's
jump to the next day. As you can see,
price opened here above the EMAs. I was
bullish, but we broke all the EMAs with
momentum. My bias switched. Then, I
waited for a bullish FVG to be printed.
We have one here, and also waited for
the price to break this bullish FVG to
have an entry trigger. This is exactly
how my strategy works. If you want to
full breakdown, you will find the link
in the description. So, I entered after
this candle closed. I placed my stop
loss over the FVG, over the inversion
candle, and also over the previous
candle/swing high, and targeted this
previous liquidity, but I was stopped
out in this candle. This day, I lost 3k.
I have no problem with that. This is a
purely a statistical loss. Now, let's
jump to the next day. On this day, price
opened under the all the EMAs. My bias
was bearish, of course. I waited for a
bullish FVG to be printed. We have one
here. Price broke it with this candle.
This is my entry trigger. I placed my
stop loss over the FVG, the inversion
candle, and previous candle, and also I
was stopped out. I lost also 3k. This is
the single week in 2026 that I got three
losses in it, but I ended up making 10k
for this week because I'm super
confident in my strategy. My one-on-one
students are also super confident in my
strategy. They have been killing it.
Look at the screenshot above. They have
been killing it in the execution. They
have been killing it in the account
stacking, the prop firms, everything.
So, if you are 100% willing to put the
work, ready to invest in yourself, ready
to stop throwing money from the window
like you're doing currently with prop
firms, ready to stop wasting your time,
click the link below to book a call with
me and apply to see if you are the right
fit. Now, let's jump to the next day.
Like you know, on Monday we don't take
pre-market FVGs like you see here. This
would be a loss because pre-market FVGs
are low probability especially on
Mondays. But, when I saw that the market
opened bullish, then the sell-off
started with big momentum candle. I
simply looked at the left and saw a
pre-market FVG that is high in the price
action because we are now bearish.
That's why I decided to take this trade.
I took an entry right here, placed my
stop loss over the green EMA, the
pre-market FVG, and over the inversion
candle, so three layers of protection.
Then, targeted the opening of the day
for a liquidity. The RR was for this
trade 2.88. I made a little bit under
9K. Now, let me tell you this, I didn't
break my rules of taking this trade
because I didn't take a pre-market FVG
entry right here. I took it only because
we switched bias and we switched bias
with a good momentum to the downside.
That's why I predicted that it will be a
directional day. That's why I took a
pre-market FVG. Now, let's go to the
second trade that I took. If you see on
June, this is the second time that I'm
taking two trades per day. So, I'm 90%
of the time taking only one trade per
day. So, for this trade, I've seen that
this candle broke all the three EMAs
with good momentum. That means I
switched my bias and I'm now bullish. I
saw that we have a bearish FVG right
here. I waited for the price to break
it. It happened with this small doji
candle. I entered here, placed my stop
loss under the inversion candle, under
the FVG, and under the EMAs. So, three
layers of protection and targeted two
hours. This was the second trade on
Monday, as you can see here a little bit
over 6K. Now, let's go to the next
trade.
We are obviously bullish. The 9:30
candle flipped all these pre-market
FVGs. The placement of these two FVGs is
what made me took this trade. If we
didn't have these FVGs, I would not be
taking this trade only because these are
two high in the price action. I entered,
placed my stop loss under all the three
FVGs, and also the EMA, and targeted two
hours. So, for the day, the 30th of
June, I made a little bit over 6K, and
ended the month with $58,000 on my
personal account. I still trade prop
firms. You can find screenshots about
here. I don't share them publicly, but
for my one-on-one students, we work
purely with prop firms. How to literally
make them, how to scale, how to take
multiple payouts in the week, how to
implement my exact strategy on prop
firms, and and how to choose the perfect
prop firms for my exact strategy, how to
rotate the accounts, etc., etc. Make
sure to like, subscribe, drop all your
comments down below. I will make sure to
answer every one of them, and let's meet
on the next one.